ربيع شاهين طفل سوري من محافظه اللاذقيه
اسمه اخباره من اسابيع محطه اهتمام كثير
من الناس والسبب فيديو قصير عبر فيه عن
حلمه واليوم حلم ربيع تحقق للي ما سمع ايش
كان حلم ربيع خلينا نسمعه
اذا بتروح الملعب بتاخد معك مين
بعد
ان شاء الله وان شاء الله
شو اسمك انت وين ساكن انا بمسبح الشمس
ولدنا يحب النصر السعودي هنا نحنا في
سوريا وهذا البطل يبغى يشوف كريستيانو
رونالدو ما ندري يمكن في يوم من الايام
اشوفك في الملعب
الفيديو اللي شفتوه لربيع خلال مقابله
اجريت معه اثناء تغطيه اثار الزلزال
المدمر في سوريا وبراءه ربيع وكلامه عن
حلمه بلقاء النجمه البرتغالي لاعب نادي
النصر السعودي كريستيانو رونالدو خطف قلوب
الكثيرين من الناس ومن بينهم رئيس هيئه
الترفيه المستشار تركي ال الشيخ اللي اعاد
نشر الفيديو عنوان التغريده بعباره ترحيب
بالطفل واسرته في المملكه وطلب من الناس
انه يوصلوا للطفل وفعلا ما في ايام الا
وشفنا فيديو لربيعه وامه واخوانه في مطار
الرياض وبيعبروا عن سعادتهم بالتواجد في
السعوديه والحماس مليله انه راح يلتقي
اسطوره رونالدو
يوم كان حلمي يشوف رونالدو اليوم انا
احاول كريستيانو رونالدو لانيتو بيعرف
يلعب طابه
ويعرف نفسي يكون العب نفسه وتدرب بالنص
السعودي
[موسيقى]
ويا رب تفوزي النص السعودي
حبيبي طيب ومن بعد ما حقق تركي ال الشيخ
حلمي ربيع عبر عبر بتغريده عن فرحته
بالموضوع اما ربيع فقال انه مو مصدق انه
حلمو تحقق
[موسيقى]
ايمت يخلص هالحلم ما بعرف
ان شاء الله ما يكون حلم يا رب
طيب مو بس ربيع ففي طفل سعودي من ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه اسمه ابراهيم العنيزي
نشر فيديو عبر تيك توك وقال للمستشار تركي
ال الشيخ انه النصراوي وانه حلمو يحضر
للنصر مباراه ويلتقي برونالدو وفعلا بعد
ان انتشرت صوره من لقاء ابراهيم برونالدو
[موسيقى]
يا شيخ احضر لي مباراه وديه
حلمي انتظرني
طيب ربيع وابراهيم ماده رحلاتهم من بعد ما
التقوا برونالدو فشفناهم
وحقيقه الفيديوهات لوحدها بتعكس كم الفرحه
والسعاده اللي شعره فيها
[موسيقى]